boa tarde quando o primeiro ministro do
canadá é você estudou assumir o poder em
2015 é perguntaram a ele o porquê dele
provocou aquela ideia porque ele
provocou aquele ministério então
igualitário na proporção entre homens e
mulheres
naquela ocasião ele respondeu porque
estamos em 2015 é um motivo muito
parecido que me traz aqui hoje o fato de
estarmos no século 21 apesar de que
cronologicamente nós estamos no século
21 mas culturalmente é como se nós
estivéssemos ainda vivendo os padrões os
comportamentos e as tendências de vários
séculos atrás
isso porque a gente ainda perpetua
certos padrões certos comportamentos que
nos limitam enquanto pessoas e esses
padrões eles são impostos a nós
simplesmente por causa do nosso gênero
porque nós somos homens ou porque nós
somos mulheres
a gente deve se comportar de uma maneira
prescrita que basicamente nos limita e
muitas vezes é bem verdade que as
pessoas são felizes cumprindo esses
papéis mas outras talvez gostaria de ter
a liberdade de escolher de não ser
daquela forma
nesse sentido aos homens acaba se
atribuindo a função de serem agressivos
de serem vires para que a sua
masculinidade não seja questionada
da mesma maneira eles precisam ser
provedores enquanto as mulheres elas
precisam ser verificadas ser retratadas
se responsabilizarem pelas tarefas do
lar pelas pelo cuidado dos filhos e
existem pessoas que de fato comprei sem
questionar esses papéis
existem outras por outro lado que não
tem opção que gostariam de exercer
tantos outros papéis
no entanto a gente ainda se submete a
falta de escolha no entanto a gente
ainda se acaba tornando a mulher para
ver uma figura mais submissa coisa que
provavelmente ela não deveria ser e é
justamente por isso por causa dessa
existência desses padrões desse
comportamento tão injustos e tão nocivos
que as mulheres tiveram que tratará a
travar lutas durante vários anos de
lutas muito recentes inclusive para que
elas tivessem direito ao voto para que
elas tivessem acesso ao mercado de
trabalho inclusive para aquelas
tivessem acesso a direitos mais básicos
ainda como educação
nesse contexto vocês provavelmente se
lembrem da figura da mala uma jovem que
hoje tem 20 anos é uma líder ativista
respeitado no mundo inteiro mas que aos
15 anos foi perseguida foi considerado
uma figura subversiva e bastante
transgressor arns a perseguição chegou
inclusive a ser avaliada no país
no paquistão pelo grupo talibã
simplesmente por causa que é a causa
dela desafiava o status co desafiava o
lugar que a mulher deveria ocupar aquela
sociedade e aquele lugar era muito fixo
para a cabeça dela não só para ela mas
para todas as meninas porque as meninas
não devem necessariamente ocupar
determinados tipos de lugares elas podem
querer sim a ir além e às vezes a gente
parte do princípio de que elas estão
sendo muito transgressores quando elas
querem ir além
mas não ela estão direito delas elas
querem simplesmente sejam reconhecidas
quanto os homens e não necessariamente
se colocarem acima delas caso contrário
não faria sentido falar na idéia de
igualdade
quando a gente fala de quando a gente
compara na verdade quando o brasil se
compara com uma nação como paquistão por
exemplo talvez a gente se acha um país
muito avançado muito bem resolvido no
que diz respeito sobretudo essas
questões de gênero mas a gente se mude
muito o nosso próprio respeito
a gente parte do princípio de que aqui
simplesmente porque a gente não utiliza
burca a gente pode vestir aquilo que a
gente quiser vamos redondamente
enganados porque a gente sabe que quando
a gente veste aquilo que a gente quer
especialmente nós mulheres
a gente é ridicularizada a gente está
sujeita a diversos julgamentos e para
algumas pessoas inclusive a nossa roupa
justifica uma sede
essa questão do assédio deve nos tocar
profundamente mas antes dela ainda quero
falar também a respeito da questão da
inclusão da mulher no mercado de
trabalho
a gente parte do princípio ainda de que
essa também é uma questão é bem
resolvido no brasil mas também não é que
não basta estar no mercado de trabalho
mas sem questionar em que condições a
gente chegou nesse mercado de trabalho
em que condições a gente pagar ocupando
este mercado de trabalho
isso porque considerando as empresas
privadas no brasil apenas 37% delas são
liberados
mulheres no setor público esse número
ainda menor de 20%
isso apesar de as mulheres serem maior
parte da população cerca de 51% e isso
apesar delas terem ainda uma
escolaridade um pouco maior do que a dos
homens
os clubes estudam em média 7,6 anos
enquanto as mulheres é estudam cerca de
oito anos
essa questão ela é mais um aqui marca
esses padrões ainda hierarquizam antes e
ainda misóginos também que partem do
princípio de que deve haver algum tipo
de dominação entre gêneros porque sempre
se partir do princípio de que talvez o
homem tem uma capacidade mais ea mulher
que sempre foi silenciada nunca se falou
a respeito da capacidade dela afinal de
contas o que é que todos torna
teoricamente menos capazes do tipo do
que os homens
a questão da do mercado de trabalho
diretas diretamente associada também a
questão da sad que acontece tanto dentro
quanto fora no mercado de trabalho e
prova disso é essa são as lutas é por
exemplo as lutas e os questionamentos
que têm acontecido em óleo protagonizado
por diversas atrizes que se abrem e
falam a respeito das condições às quais
elas vêm sendo submetidos no seu
ambiente de trabalho para falar do
assédio especialmente a gente muitas
vezes negligencia casos cotidianos dos
quais nós somos vítimas e quando a gente
negligencia a gente naturaliza isso ea
gente se silencia a gente na verdade
simplesmente é acaba contribuindo para
que essa realidade não seja de maneira
nenhuma esperada
talvez os casos que nos desperta em mais
indignação são os casos mais extremos
mas tanto os casos considerados mais
banais infelizmente que são mais
negligenciados quanto os casos mais
extremos entram para as estatísticas
sem diferença mas como a gente indigna
provavelmente com os casos mais extremos
é bom citar um que aconteceu em são
paulo no ano passado quando o dentro do
transporte público no ônibus um
passageiro já colocou no pescoço da
outra
naquela situação mesmo que a mulher
se não tenha sido tão vulneráveis tenha
sido colocada naquela situação o juiz
responsável pelo caso considerou que não
havia sido estupro porque não houve uso
de violência tampouco grave ameaça ou
sequer constrangimento ea palavra
constrangimento ela tem um peso
especialmente grande porque nós mulheres
convivemos com um constrangimento
diariamente
toda vez que nós somos é alvo de um
olhar mais indesejável de um olhar mais
indiscreto cujo significado a gente
conhece ou toda vez ainda que o nosso
corpo é tocado sem o nosso consentimento
porque se parte do princípio de que o
nosso corpo não é nosso dever nosso
corpo está a serviço é de outra pessoa
mas não diante de casos como esse seja
ele mais extremo o menor considerado
menor o mais reverenciado não interessa
a roupa que a mulher estava vestindo o
lugar que ela estava freqüentando toda
vez que você relativiza a palavra da
mulher você ao invés de apoiá lá você em
nosso comportamento do agressor e
contribui para que isso seja ainda uma
freqüente e para que essa realidade
ainda não mude no brasil afinal de
contas porque a gente questionam roupa
lugar
afinal de contas o que a gente quer
combater o assédio ou é o nosso direito
à nossa própria segurança ea nossa
própria liberdade para falar em números
a gente precisa citar que no brasil a
cada sete minutos uma mulher é agredida
a cada 11 minutos uma mulher é vítima de
estupro e diariamente sete mulheres são
vítimas de feminicídio morrem apenas por
serem mulheres morrem apenas porque
estão ainda sujeitas a uma lógica
obsessiva e misógina que parte do
princípio de que nós somos menores ou de
que nós devemos ser silenciados por
alguma razão
toda vez que isso acontece toda vez que
as relações humanas
de alguma maneira são hierarquizadas
conforme gênero essa dominação dá lugar
à desumanização
e aqui não se trata por exemplo de pedir
direitos a mais
tampouco privilégios trata simplesmente
da gente querer garantias de direitos
que sempre foram tão acessíveis para os
homens é eo que me traz aqui
diante de todas as histórias pessoais
que eu tive que emite o que me traz aqui
é são as cicatrizes que eu sei que
amigas minhas carregam seja elas
cicatrizes físicas ou psicológicas e eu
tô aqui ainda também por muito respeito
a todos os homens que freqüentemente já
se deram conta de que vale muito mais a
pena nos apoiar porque a gente pode
estar lado a lado e não faz sentido que
um esteja acima do outro a gente não
pode colaborar para que essa lógica
pessoa ainda exista e eu tô aqui ainda
também é é agradecida e muito
esperançosa graças a uma geração de
meninas que tem crescido cada vez mais
consciente e tem renovado as minhas
esperanças de dias melhores
especialmente para as mulheres eu estou
aqui
o profundo respeito a uma mulher chamada
maria da penha e lutou pela sua
sobrevivência pela sobrevivência de
tantas outras mulheres que sempre foram
desprotegidos não tinha uma lei que
amparasse estou aqui por todas as
mulheres que de alguma maneira se
silenciam diante de relacionamentos
abusivos por medo do ac de topo
admiração ainda respeito a todas as
outras mulheres que tiveram coragem de
denunciar
tô aqui ainda movida por um sentimento
de superioridade muito grande
estou aqui porque finalmente lugar de
mulher é onde ela quiser
[Música]
[Aplausos]